[Music]
hello everyone
we will continue our discussion of the
kinematics chapter
and will continue with strain
so in the previous lecture previous part
of the lecture
we had seen that the
d small x square the magnitude square
can be expressed by this huge thing
where each one of this
e 1 1 e 2 2 etc these are
given by these huge expressions in turn
now with this knowledge in hand
it is very much possible to
denote this equation
in a very neat and clean fashion using
the index notation
so we'll do that very quickly and we'll
see that it is not just for the purpose
of
denoting it in a nice and clean fashion
later on we'll see that the use of the
index notation
will also help us in deriving some very
useful
formula so with that in mind
we'll quickly write down the this
particular equation
again but using the index notation
right so
the d small x square magnitude
we take the magnitude of the vector
square
and that is equal to so quickly glancing
back at the previous slide
this entire thing which is uh
the d capital x vector magnitude square
so
now the rest of it
this thing this is where we are actually
going to use the index notation
so this can be quickly written down as
twice
the x i d
x j e
i j where each of these
eijs for different combinations of
i and j will be denoting each of those
e11 e2 to e33 that we have seen in the
previous slide now it is very important
to note
uh and in general it is always important
to note that whenever we use the index
notation we should check
very quickly before proceeding any
further whether the consistency
of the order of the tenses is maintained
in the equation or not so what do i mean
by the consistency of the order of the
tenses
you see in this equation it's actually a
very simple thing so
uh you see on the left hand side we have
this dx vector
which is itself a vector a 10 which is
more formally a tensor of order one but
when we take the magnitude of that
you understand very well that this is a
scalar so that's a scalar square
so it is very much a scalar again so the
left hand side is a scalar
so it is absolutely necessary that the
right hand side has to be a scalar
so that is what is uh meant by the
consistency
of the order of the tenses so first now
the first term on the right hand side
that poses no problem we are
we know that just like the left hand
side this first term
on the right hand side this one the d
capital x vector magnitude
that is very much a scalar the square of
that is a scalar no problem
now what about this term uh now
you see here there is an index
i but it is not a free index
it is actually repeated here so here is
a i
and here is another i as the first index
of the
second order tensor e i j so i repeat
i is repeated here similarly the index j
which is present here
that also is repeated so all the indices
that are present
in this term they are repeated there is
not a single free index
so these uh these repeated indices uh
you perhaps have already come across
this term they are also
referred to as dummy indices so they do
not contribute
to the order of the tensor so overall
here because there is not a single free
index
whatever indices are there there in the
form of dummy indices
or repeated indices the order of the
tensor here is
0. now we know that the tensor of order
0 is nothing but a scalar
so this term again is also a scalar so
overall as far as the consistency of the
orders
of the orders orders of the tensors is
concerned the left hand side
is perfectly matching with the right
hand side they are all scalars that is
what is basically meant here
now
it will be also useful to
write down very quickly the expression
in
index notation for this e i j
so
where e i j is equal to
so what we are attempting here it will
be a massive
uh save in uh in labor
uh you see whatever i had written in the
previous slide here
to these six equations these six
expressions one two three four five six
expressions uh that i am going to write
down
in a single shot using the index
notation
how can i do that so
half del
ui del xj
plus del uj
del xi plus
del u k
del x i del u k
del x j
now if you are not very familiar with
the index notation
uh it might seem like almost like black
magic to what i have what i've just done
but if you're a little bit familiar if
you have practiced a little bit with the
index notation you will see that
whatever we have written down in the
previous slide through these large
expressions
they are exactly replicated through
different choices of the i
and j here and you can actually test it
out yourself
by simply uh substituting
for example i equal to 1 j equal to 1
here
in which case you will you should be
able to get back the
expression for e 1 1 that we had written
earlier
and please note that i am not saying
anything about the k
because the k here is a repeated index
which means
that summation is implied here so no
matter what you
what choice of i and j you have the k is
always going to be repeated so
it is in fact representing three terms
in itself so there should be
uh u one one here a u two two here and a
u three three here
and which is how you obtain
these three terms where you'll see that
in each of these you have a u1 u2 u3
here is
also you have u1 u2 u3 similarly let's
say
or e23 we have u11 here u22 here u33
here
so all of these things can be obtained
by uh
such by repeating the index k here so
i'll
quickly put down a note here so you can
check for yourself by substituting
different values of i
and j
[Music]
by putting
different values of i and j
sorry
[Music]
of i and j
you should be able to obtain whatever we
had written in the
previous slide okay
now we quickly note down
a few important things here so
this e i j
which is basically
in compact notation this second order
tensor
this is referred to as the finite strain
tensor
so this is referred to as the finite
strain tensor and immediately
uh you should be asking yourself so does
it mean that there is something like a
non-finite or an infinitesimal strain
tensor
so answer is yes there is very much uh
such a strain tensor and which is what
actually we'll be using throughout
the rest of this course and we'll
discuss about that a little later
the next important thing to note as i've
already mentioned is that
this e i j because you see uh it has
two free indices there are no repeated
indices here so i is a free index
j is a pre-index uh so it is
a second order 10 set so
it's a second order tensor
furthermore we have already seen that
e i j is equal to
e j i
so we have discussed about that in the
previous part of the lecture
uh which is what
actually led to the presence of these
factors
of 2 here so we had discussed
that e 1 2 is exactly equal to e 2 1
e 2 3 is exactly equal to e 3 2 and e
3 1 is exactly equal to e13 and that is
what is
meant in brief in the index notation
by writing this thing as eij is equal to
eji
and that basically means that
is symmetric
now in terms of actual use so
this second order tensor here basically
means that
in terms of the matrix representation it
can be
expressed as a
this e i j
[Music]
it can be represented
as a 3
into 3 matrix
so what i mean by that is you have
e 1 1 e 1
2 e 1 3
now
strictly speaking we have e 2 1 here
but we have already seen that e21
is equal to e12 so we don't need to
write this separately
so we'll put it back as e12
[Music]
this is e23 similarly
ideally i should be putting here e31 but
i understand that p31 is equal to e13
so i just put it put this as e13
similarly here i should be putting here
as
e32 but i'll just use e23 because both
of them are equal
and finally i have e33 and that is in
the form of a
matrix so you see
that the six components
that we had written here these six
components that are present here in the
previous slide
they they are captured within this
matrix you have actually
six independent components here one two
three
four five and six okay
so one last thing about this symmetric
second order
tensor is that if you go back to this
expression
you note that this is a linear term
this itself is a linear term what i mean
by linear here
is that uh this is
of course a first order derivative but
there is no square or any higher order
powers
involved here it is also not multiplied
with another second
or another first first order term
but this third term this
by itself is a first order derivative
this by itself is a first order
derivative
but since they are multiplied together
these
are actually the non-linear
contributions to the definition of this
eij and we can explicitly see that
in the previous slide where you see here
the first one the del u 1 del x 1
all these things here also del u 1
del x 2 plus del u 2 del x 1 all these
things they are the linear parts but
here you have
the non-linear or the actually the
quadratic parts so here is the quadratic
nature represented by this uh degree 2.
uh here also you have uh so there is no
degree 2 here but they are actually
multiplied together
two linear terms are multiplied together
so they are the quadratic terms here
so you understand that overall
the expression of the finite strain
tensor
it involves in general this kind of
non-linear terms
now in the next part of the lecture what
we are going to discuss is
what happens if the magnitude
of each of these linear terms is very
very small
so we are going to discuss that next
thank you